women march is women's history month a
time to reflect on women's strength
power contributions but also time to
look forward and inspire other women i
talked to a local woman who spent her
career finding that magic and she's
sharing her tips for success
i would not be standing here today if i
didn't have a good peer group around me
of women emily vavra is a wellness
leader a speaker and entrepreneur she
says even in the most dire times
gratitude helped her succeed i had a
journal and i would write out 10 things
i was grateful for even the mattress on
the floor when i didn't have a bed frame
and the pillow that i was resting my
head on
and when you express gratitude you
actually raise your frequency and your
energy immensely she says it's vital
that we practice that thankfulness and
pass it on let's let the ripple effect
go out there across the world i believe
that women need other women the key she
says is to stop sabotaging your own
dreams first of all our self-talk so
number one i had to learn
to really think about what i was
thinking about her tip to do that is
simple and i actually heather wore a
rubber band
around
my wrist and i would snap it
when i would start to have negative
self-talk
it's that physical reminder of what's
going on in your brain she also says
find someone you're inspired by follow
them read their books watch their
youtube channel whatever it takes
something that moves you
and there's your inspiration starts it's
that simple i'm inspired let's do it up
next